robs had spent years trying and failing
to conquer the game he loved and it's
just rocks young estonian's first time
in the playoffs certainly impressed but
it's not been enough but he didn't let
the cheating accusations stop him his
incredible play Shone through even when
his teams didn't yeah that smoke man
actually helped him although robs and a
great call to the spray is in and he
gets oh
headshots in a row unbelievable and
that's gonna be overtime look at Oscar
just laughing still a major win would
clinch his rise to super stardom in a
way that nothing else could
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
Robin Rob's cool represents a new
generation of Counter-Strike players I
think it was like 15 when I started
playing CS go I watched the first few
tournaments and they were like the same
guys who were playing the older version
and I saw that they're getting really
old at this point and I was like okay
I'm at the age that they were starting
from a young age she
sure in Competitive Gaming and to that
end he even applied to join FaZe Clan
okay hello my dudes I am Robson this is
my phase five uh recruitment challenge
response powered by Chief field robs
played a variety of FPS titles making
content for Call of Duty 1.6 and
eventually CS go and as he developed the
skills rops displayed in FPL streams of
pro players showed that he was able to
hang with the game's best a lot of the
people in Estonia grinded face it and I
got into the basic rounds there was a
lot of money on the line it was really
competitive since you were already
playing for something he attracted a of
attention and was quickly becoming one
of the game's most anticipated
up-and-comers the way I got scouted um
it was it was very fast it was like
becoming a hero from nobody but the same
skills that were getting him noticed
were also drawing cheating accusations
in some parts of the community a
traumatic experience for a player
looking to make his start
can you stop playing like [__] drops
please we need your cheats man watch
this [__] man he does like these quick
looks that's so weird bro like why are
you doing that he even had to fly to the
face at studios in London and play FPL
from there to prove that he wasn't
cheating obviously like um all the
cheating allegations and stuff like that
was uh we're pretty rough on me because
I those are the people I I tried to uh
look up to and I tried to pick up one of
them and then they kind of went against
me eventually though once robs did join
a professional team he was given a rare
opportunity to continue attending school
in his home country of Estonia while
still traveling and playing
competitively it is still going in
school even now when we're playing at
the big tournaments because this school
is like really willing to let him live
this dream but that didn't mean that his
life was easy between the cheating
accusations and managing his packed
schedule rops also faced significant
personal challenges like the terrible
life-changing news he received from his
mom while practicing CS one day my mom
came into my room
and I was like okay don't bother me I'm
playing I'm busy now and I'm just having
some fun but she said it's serious and
she just sent me down to have a talk and
she let me know that
um my dad committed suicide the tragedy
shookrops and upended his life we had
some problems with like bankruptcy the
bank had to take this house so I could
just go back in time and you know it's
all something like that that I could
earn so much money playing Cs and I just
wait like
things will work out Rob's stuck with cs
he committed himself to the game hoping
to make a better life for his family
with his skills the only thing he really
lacked was experience but despite his
unproven track record On LAN Mouse
Sports saw Ross's potential and decided
to take a chance on him in April of
2017. a gamble that turned out to be a
no-brainer I know there's one within the
site he's gonna be rubbing back with the
man in heaven moropsy does it and now
buddy
one V2 if he finds one of these this
round is over he turns into one on one
but robs lands the shot he somehow does
it Dan and Elise now have to watch as
their tournament hopes hang in the
balance Oscar extends it twist now joins
them as it's down to Nitro alone just
Nitro Oscar's got two stickers gonna
finish it and mouth Sports they've done
it don't slow down the bomb is on the
ground Kirby finds additional chances
here but he is now the last man standing
with the UMP
Kirby
shot in the back and that's it 16-9
Mouse Sports and one of the core
principles behind Moses transformation
was the idea that while rops was indeed
a formidable aimer the entire roster
would need to pitch in to find wins good
no one can say that if Nico was in this
team they would probably be better right
but it's not revolving around one single
player anymore it's more about team
making good decisions and playing well
as a unit instead as exciting as robs's
rookie season in 2017 was he didn't make
hltv's top 20 players list and for the
next year or so Mouse consistently
struggled on the game's biggest stages
do you find Oscar at the lockers as well
after taking down the long shot
carrigate is sunny and it's just romps
young estonian's first time in the
playoffs
certainly impressed but it's not been
enough two-nothing for phase they'll
move through to the semi-final and our
favorites move on definitely not
released but Mouse squads it's the same
heartbreaking story close but no cigar
again it wasn't all bad news though robs
and his teammates were able to steal ESL
one New York out from underneath liquid
a few months later Chris again it's all
to twist he knows it the young rookie so
much skill he knows where the bomb is he
knows there's a smoke on it he's got it
no he doesn't he doesn't Sonny's got
away with it no Sports win it the Battle
of Brooklyn and they're back to winning
after the roster change and as hltv
writer Marco Rizzo pointed out from a
pure value perspective this roster was
punching way above its weight class for
much of 2018 plus three of the players
on the team were in the top 20 list in
2018 including rops who made his debut
in the 19th spot but after the team
failed to qualify for 2019's first major
they decided to make some serious
changes and bring in on new leader
despite being regarded as one of the
best igls in the world Kerrigan had
never won a major but if Mouse wanted to
add depth then he was almost certainly
their best choice given any kind of
players around him he would almost
immediately figure out how to use them
and how to play the best Counter-Strike
I think it's one of the reason why he's
regarded as one of the greatest ignos
out there and as of March 2019 mouse was
carrigan's puzzle to figure out this
could be a cut like in the making right
now from X7 he's picked up the awp for
Carrigan he's got the off angle he's
nailed it and that's it Mouse Force they
came back against tyloo and they've won
against ants I cannot believe that
they've done this the relationship
between Kerrigan and robs was critical
to Moses success but it was also history
repeating itself eight years earlier a
young Kerrigan had joined Moses 1.6
roster helmed by legendary German igl
gar B hoping to build his career and
learn learn from one of the greats that
was one of the guys who helped me
achieve my highest level in 1.6 he was a
God in 1.6 as a cola as also as a mentor
his motivation the way he cares about
the teammates the way he tried to
explain stuff I took much of his style
into my leading as well I mixed with
every players every everyone right but
there was something about being this
motivator and the leader of the team
which was very um first time I ever
experienced that now it was Kerrigan's
turn to Mentor robs to guide him through
this critical time in his career where
both the pressure and the expectations
were at their Peak but the Mao's team
Dynamic was decidedly lopsided besides
Chris J all of the players were young
up-and-comers who were eager to please
and that didn't always give Kerrigan the
best information you know like I was a
mentor to the whole team but sometimes I
think Gambit also needs someone to
battle him in a nice way that means they
we need to figure this out we need to do
this differently right we had a coach
doing that but I feel like having one
two voices is not enough in a team I
think three voice is always the best way
because you're gonna have
um disagreements and agreements and
everybody has their own view of the game
and you mix together all those views I
think that's the way we become the best
team in the world and not just only two
guys running the whole show while they
narrowly missed the cut for playoffs
that the only other major That season
Berlin the team grew tremendously and
was once again a critical part of their
success earning ESL pro league MVP
honors and inching up the hltv top 20
list to number 10 that year but the game
itself was about to change drastically
and robs is budding success would hit a
serious roadblock it was just after I
challenge when we won and it was like
looking like it's going to be the best
year I've ever had so far but it's quite
the turn in the end and yeah we just we
just uh
in 2020 it felt like Mouse Sports
couldn't catch a break they started the
year off at number two in the world
right behind astralis but things went
off the rails quickly he knows they're
coming towards his location he's been
hiding behind the sight another shot
hits but it's not enough gratisfaction
secures it 100 thieves are off to the
playoffs they take down Front Runners
for the playoffs mouth Sports and the
lower bracket run is complete by August
they were out of the top 20 entirely and
roster changes were the order of the day
the golden winter of 2019 was but a
distant memory even so robs continued to
put up impressive numbers with Eerie
consistency not only that but the loss
of a walk sick meant that robs had to
sometimes pitch in as the Opera as well
we need all to make sure we don't get
out oh my God this play from Chris turns
to two oh sorry rocks and stop Amir he's
knocking him down like bowling pins he
gets four is he on for the ace he is
naffle
tucked hail and run he's back to spawn
Rob's relief behind this
is so damn cool whatever the issue with
mouse was it certainly wasn't robs on
the bright side the ever-changing team
comps and Moses lack of success helped
him mature as a competitor outside the
server as well I had like all the
decisions being made for me I didn't
really do anything I was like the guy
who was told this to you do your own
thing and just play good and you're fine
and that's that's basically what happens
but over time obviously
um me and the organization is obviously
more in touch and we talk more about
what what the solutions can be and what
what we should do in in general in early
2021 Carrigan left Mouse to return to
FaZe Clan and the roster was thrown into
chaos robs kept up his staggering
consistency but the real trick was
getting everyone firing at the same time
they managed it at Flashpoint 3 but
reproducing that success proved
difficult still robs used this
tumultuous period to grow and develop as
a player carving out a spot for himself
in a lineup That was struggling to find
an identity robs has started to become
more aggressive he's taking more opening
duels he's starting to play for map
control a little bit faster he's running
a little bit more and while his team
couldn't go deep at the bends they
certainly got as far as they did mainly
because of Rob's efforts which were
again recognized with a third top 20
placement in a row but 2021 would be the
last year that props wore Moe's Jersey
as he followed his one-time mentor to a
bright International future
FaZe Clan had almost everything they had
a tenacious flexible role player a young
electric Opera a fiery rifler with
inhuman aim and a Killer Instinct and a
mastermind to run the whole damn thing
but they didn't have romps when rupps
was signed to Face Clan it made an awful
lot of sense you look at the paper you
look at the lineup being put together
right here and we all agreed that wow
that is a lot that is supposed to win
trophies that is a lineup That is
supposed to go file major and it did
make a lot of sense for one Kerrigan
knew exactly what the team was getting
since he already had experience working
with romps the roster had plenty of
Firepower but they weren't adding a
streaky highlight machine or an unknown
quantity to the mix they were adding
rops a player who had shown incredible
consistency in a difficult team
situation and even managed to evolve his
personal play style during that volatile
time if he could do that imagine what he
do with FaZe gives you a round like this
everybody falls at the hands of rain and
this
and this clan with a sweet sweet revenge
now off of the back of the Norwegian
rain AKA picked back up by Alexi B but
he was tagged in the process Hunter
instead they'll get jks
[Applause]
oh they lined up he's actually hit one
plus two he did damage that's gonna drop
them down a dollar Hunter
[Applause]
boots it will take a championship and
you can see what it means to Kerrigan
they're so locked in they have to know
it as well broke he's gonna grab the
angle with an awp he's not going to shy
away I'll step around that smoke blinded
a little bit but surely he's going to
come back for it all of phase ready to
fight there's the flashbang broke he's
got one more and there's rain phase have
done it they take the series three to
one and phase are gonna be your
Champions even as part of a super team
robs still stood out earning MVP at ESL
Pro League season 15 but the real
challenge still lay ahead pgl major
Antwerp was faced his first chance to
test their new roster on
counter-strike's biggest stage none of
them had ever won a major but the
remnants of faze's old roster had been
agonizingly close if FaZe could win an
antwer they'd be the first ever
international roster to do so but their
campaign got off to a rough start
oh but even that date's not enough oh
Jesus and now this one's done dude yeah
wrap it up hence they strike First Blood
a little bit of sweet revenge but as the
matches rolled on the team found their
footing earning a spot in the playoff
stage
and over towards the arch it's a
[__] from hampus man Advantage for
phases they push into this site and
hence the time
move on to the semi-finals they crushed
A Cinderella Story in the semi-finals
[Applause]
before
and then on the very doorstep of the
grand finale the greatest of all time
barred robs's entry but his hard work
had already gotten him this far he would
just have to work even harder to bring
it home now these trades are so strong
does not surrender
Ed Bobby's half gone navi's hopes and
dreams with it a couple of kills is all
they need and there's one simple snowman
robs meets his fate and is only broken
for Faith across the line
[Applause]
and brave he's not done he gets his 30
and phase two breaks away
[Applause]
it's tempting to think that Rob's skills
meant that his big win was inevitable
but getting there took a lot more than
just sick aim it took a country
community and family who believed in him
even as his future opponents accused him
of cheating and he faced deep personal
loss it took a willingness to learn from
the game's greats and to work harder
every day to show that he was invested
in going all the way to the top robs
belonged on FaZe Clan and belonged on
that stage he proved it over and over so
consistently that it was never a note
and in Antwerp Rob showed us that he
belonged in the history books too and at
only 23 years old he has a hell of a lot
more of that history to write
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and Tech talk
[Music]